[MUSIC]
Hello, welcome everyone.
We're so excited that you could join us
today for our partners and families panel.
It's thrilling to have you all here and
I thank you so much for
making some time to be with us today.
So first up, just to ground us a little
bit and what's going to happen next.
We're going to have about
55 minutes together today.
And well, I will be on hand to hopefully
answer some basic technical or
logistical questions about applying and
navigating the Stanford MBA experience.
This time is really meant to be spent
with our students, our alumni, and
their partners to really understand and
get a deeper appreciation for
the Stanford GSB experience
from their perspective.
So I'll kick things off
with a few questions, but
I really invite all of you to
utilize this Q&A box this evening.
And feel free to ask any questions
that are on your mind today,
as it will be helpful for you.
All right, so a few things before
we get started because this
is a little different than maybe some
of our traditional sessions where we're
talking just strictly about some
of the academic experiences.
This is a huge commitment that
you're thinking about making and
we know this isn't a decision
you're making on your own,
others are involved in this
decision making process with you.
And so it's important to
understand that here at Stanford,
there are a number of resources and
support systems in place for
not only our students, but for
the members of their families as well.
So we do actually have on campus and
Stanford affiliated housing that you and
your partners and families can be moving
into on campus, which is pretty great.
For those of you who may be moving here
from another geographic location and
your partner is thinking about
conducting their own job search,
we do actually have some
career support for them.
There are also support systems in
terms of student organizations and
family clubs and
other activities that partners and
families can be involved
in during their time here.
Something else, just mentioning,
at a high level today for all of you,
our financial aid is need based.
And if you are coming with a spouse or
a family member or kids,
all of that is factored into the need
based financial aid process.
In addition to that,
this was actually some new information for
me as I prepared for this session.
There's actually some additional funds and
grants available for
families here at Stanford.
So if you have more questions about that,
I can try to pop some of those links into
the chats during our discussion today.
All right, so with that,
I just wanted to do a very high level.
So I'm going to ask all of our
panelists to share a little bit about
their living situation on campus because
I think it will help acclimate all of us.
We're actually very fortunate at Stanford,
there are a number of on campus graduate
housing options for our students.
So for single students, for
couples, and for families.
We have quite a number of options
both within the Stanford campus and
what they refer to as
off-campus subsidized housing,
which is a lot of housing that
might be just one or two miles.
Or in some cases, directly across
the street from Stanford's campus
right here in Palo Alto, California.
So I just wanted to let going to that,
as you are thinking about making this
big move, there are lots of options in
terms of where you might find
yourself living in the future.
So with that, I'm going to
turn things over to our panel.
I'm going to have our little intro
slide here up for just a minute and
then I'm going to actually open things up
so you can see our whole panel here today.
But what I'd like to do first is
just do a quick round for our panel.
If you could share who you are, where
you're dialing in from today yourself,
and if you lived off campus on campus.
A little bit about that because I'm sure
we'll get some more questions later.
So I'm going to bounce
around the screen here and
I think we'll kick things off with Parker.
Welcome, thanks for being here.
>> Yeah, no, thanks so much for having us.
So I'm here with Lacey and
then Lacey's got our little guy, Nate.
So bonus panelists today.
So I'm calling in, we're both calling
in from Salt Lake City, Utah.
I'm still at work.
This is a homestyle and let's see what
was we lived in Escondido village.
>> Excellent.
>> That was the family housing with the,
they're different.
There's different Escondido
village housing, but
we lived in the family housing.
>> Excellent.
And Lacey,
would you like to introduce yourself?
>> Yeah, so I came with Parker to the GSB.
We came from Texas and
at the time we had three children.
We had our fourth child while in school.
And so the family housing and
the family life is where I have
a lot of expertise at Stanford.
So if you have questions around that,
I am willing to help you to answer.
>> Wonderful, thanks so much.
Amanda, let's turn
things over to you next.
>> Hi, yes, I'm Amanda.
I am a incoming second
year MBA from Australia.
As you can see,
I come from education consulting, but
use my time at Stanford to pivot into
real estate, urban environment work.
So I'm currently interning with a real
estate developer over the summer and
I'm in Portugal, which is why it
looks like it's not time here.
Tori is my partner.
I'll let her introduce herself.
>> Excellent, and Amanda, where were
you living on campus during year one?
>> Sorry, I have lived actually
in both Jay Mack and Schwab.
The rivalry between them is false,
and it means nothing, but
if you want to get competitive, go ahead.
>> [LAUGH] Thanks,
let's turn things over to Tori.
>> Hi, I'm Tori.
I moved to Schwab to live with
Amanda from Australia and
did the whole getting a visa to work
in the US job search to get across.
So if you have any questions about that,
I'm more than happy to chat.
>> Excellent, thanks, and let's turn
things over to Natalya and Eric.
>> Hi, I'm Natalya,
we're calling in from New York.
I was class of 2020 and I lived in Schwab
my first year and I came from finance.
Now I'm starting my own company and
also am now an Esso because Eric just
started at the GSB, so
we're exactly two years apart.
>> Yeah, we did not time that out
too well, but as Natalya mentioned,
my name is Eric.
I am one of Amanda's classmates are rising
second year at the business school.
Natalya and
I live together in Schwab on this past
year which was a great experience.
And I come from a background in
healthcare and government and
I'm interning in consulting for
the summer.
Looking forward to chatting with you all.
>> Awesome, well with that I'm going to
start sharing the screen, so I can pull
everybody up, and hopefully you can see
all of us here now, as a full panel.
I am going to kick things off with
a couple of questions for the group.
And I see we've got one in the Q&A box so
far,
but get those questions coming in, and we
are going to do our best to answer as many
as possible in the next 45 minutes or so.
But to kick things off, I'll open
this up to anyone who's interested.
Maybe we'll try to hear from
from two folks at a time, and
we'll work on getting
through as much as possible.
So first up, what were some of the
important considerations that you had in
mind when preparing for graduate school?
Especially knowing that you are going
to be making this decision not just as
an individual, but a decision
that would affect others as well?
Who wants to tackle this one first?
>> I'm happy to.
So we went to grad school
at a time where we already
have three kids, as Lacey mentioned.
So I think pertinent to this This panel
discussion, for me is really important
that it wasn't just a great learning,
and development, and life experience for
me personally, but also that it was
really great for Lacey and for our kids.
And so, I think, one thing that really
helped us was seeing Escondido village,
and for those that are not familiar, it's
this sort of like grouping of townhomes.
And it's a place where you can
live if you have children.
And so, a lot of the GSB does run on
the single person's schedule, but
because we were in this
Escondido village area,
we were able to build up our own
community of other families and
other parents, and
that was an incredible opportunity.
So I think, yeah, just thinking about
who are the other people that I love,
that I care about in my life and how will
this experience affect them and making
sure that they will have an incredible
life experience as well at the same time.
>> Thanks Parker, does anyone else want to
chime in in terms of anything else that
was of consideration for
you when you were making this decision?
>> I think making sure that going in,
there's buy in from both people on term,
and expectation setting
around what type of cadence you have
to have in order to keep in touch.
And make sure depending,
we did long distance apart of it,
we weren't always in person and so,
just making sure that there was a sense
of rhythm and cadence, when we were
thinking about, how is this going to work.
What does this actually look like, if I
do make the decision to go to the school?
>> Great, thank you.
So I see Tori, Amanda, go ahead.
>> I'm sorry, go ahead if you-
>> Tory was actually answering
the question in the Q&A box,
so I just thinking-
>> Good, okay.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We obviously moved internationally,
which is a big deal.
And internationally,
during a pandemic which also,
[LAUGH ] was not particularly easy.
So when you say making sure that everybody
is committed, we had to have some very
honest and very frank conversations early,
to say not only are we going to try this
graduate school thing, but
also try the graduate school thing.
And Tory needed to find a way
to work in the United States.
Which does come with its own challenges,
and I'm sure for
those I see lots of internationals.
So for those with SOs,
who are looking to work in the US,
that's the whole tricky process as well,
which needs to get started early.
And then, I think making sure,
we can talk about this more, but
making sure that your SO has their life
too, whether it is part of a community
of partners on campus, or
families on campus, or has connection.
As well as just an SO.
>> All right, quick point of clarification
for everyone throughout our conversation
today, you may hear our panel refer
to things as SO and/or partners.
So, sort of officially we try to use
the term partners here on campus but, SO
is just part of the vernacular here at
Stanford Graduate School of Business or
the GSB, as you might hear it referred to.
So, if you ever have any questions about
any abbreviations we may be using,
feel free to pop those
in the chat questions.
Speaking of questions, I know Tory was
answering in the chat but I think this is
actually a great one for everyone to hear
as well, what are some types of events or
activities that the SOs or
partners can get involved with on campus?
So for those of you who have
been partners on campus,
do you want to share a little bit about
some of the different things that
you've been able to get involved
with during your time here?
>> Yeah, happy to.
I think SOs can be involved in a lot,
basically anything socially, [LAUGH].
I ended up spending a lot of time around
campus getting to know other people and
going to some of the social events and
on trips with others,
all of that is very much open season for
SOs.
In addition, there are definitely
some professional events,
particularly the student organized ones
that SOs are often welcome to join,
such as the student conferences and
some of the student organized sessions.
I worked in healthcare, so I went to
a session meeting someone from, gosh,
I can't remember, but
it was a large US Health insurer.
That was organized by one of the students,
obviously not class,
but to be fair, that's okay.
[LAUGH] Yeah, you can really get
involved in quite a lot if you're an SO
and motivated to involve
yourself in student life.
>> I'll answer this one also.
And I do apologize, I started reading, so
I might have to duplicate a little bit of
what Tory said, but
there are a lot of involvement you can do.
Obviously you can't attend classes because
you haven't been admitted to the program,
but if your partner or
whatever is presenting or
particularly enjoy the class, they can
always ask if you can come in, and
I think I attended every class
that was Parker's favorite.
I went at least once, there's
a view from the top where you have,
incredible people who have accomplished
a lot of things to come speak and
you can say and all of that.
You can go on trips,
I saw a question about trips.
You can't go on trips that
are organized by the school, but
there are lots of trips that are organized
by students and that's free game.
And so, the involvement is
you get in whatever you want,
you can have that experience.
So there are also groups
that you can attend, so
if you are a partner, when I was there,
it was called Biz partners.
I don't know if it's still called that,
it's still called that, okay.
And also Biz kids if you have children,
which is a great community and
a great network,
just to be able to find where you belong.
Some people have a hard time adjusting
to being at the GSB when you
are not a student, and
I recommend just holding on and
finding your people and going with it and
creating your own experience.
>> And I'm going to jump in because there
was one thing that Lacey didn't mention,
but one of the ways we got to know each
other during her time at the GSB was.
Significant others and
partners are actually able to join some of
our administrative committees on campus.
So Lacey actually worked with us in
planning our admitted student weekend.
And so, that's actually an opportunity
that's open to partners and significant
others, if you're interested in actually
helping to shape some of the activities
that we plan on campus for the new
students joining us and their families.
>> Interesting.
>> All right, looks like the next question
may also be for Parker and Lacey,
because I'm seeing a bunch in the Q&A box,
about balancing family and
the very challenging rigorous MBA
academic coursework, course load.
So Parker as the student,
can you tell us a little bit about how you
manage your prioritization and
balancing all of that.
And Lacey,
maybe any other advice you had as well for
the partner who was married
to a very busy MBA student.
>> Yeah, so I think one of the driving
forces of nature that sort of runs
underneath everything in grad school
is FOMO, the fear of missing out.
And so, I think coming into the program,
knowing that we have a family and
that my schedule typically runs very
different from somebody that maybe
doesn't have a family.
There's definitely a lot of fear of
missing out on social activities and
other things because, of course, one of
the main reasons that you do an MBA is for
developing those relationships and
a network and having those experiences.
So, I think the discipline that was
sort of naturally required was just
prioritization and
really being thoughtful about
Do I really need to go to a social
event every single night of the week?
Maybe some weeks, but
probably not most weeks.
And so I think just being super thoughtful
about what do I actually care about
participating in?
And I will say that we were really happy
with our social experiences at the GSB.
Not just connecting with other families,
but also connecting with all kinds of
different students, single, married,
with kids, without kids, etc, etc.
And I do think one thing that did help
us is realizing that when you have kids,
sometimes students that don't have
kids assume that you're too busy or
maybe you I don't want to
do something socially.
And so, we took it upon ourselves a little
bit more to try to reach out, and
invite people over for dinner just so they
knew, hey, yes we have a family, but we're
not so busy with our family that we don't
want to have that relationship with you.
So we would do it again in a heartbeat.
Our older kids have friends that they've
made that I think will be lifetime
friends they met out on
the playground in Escondido village.
So, yeah,
we would do again in a heartbeat.
>> So to piggyback on what Parker said,
I think that the biggest thing was
scheduling because there's going to be
a lot of things that your student could
do that they won't do as parents.
Because you just can't be gone every
single night until the wee hours
of the morning like a single
student might be able to.
Not to say he didn't go to Vegas for
one night thing or whatever, there's still
opportunity to enjoy that part too,
but you just have to make choices.
And for us it was, like Parker said,
inviting people to our house
where our kids felt safe and
liked meeting different people or
going to campus to meet Parker for lunch.
So you see all the students and
you make those connections still, but
in a way that's more family friendly and
more suited for
the stage of life that you might be in.
>> Thanks, Lacey.
Speaking of stages of life and where
you might be in, I would love to turn
things over to Natalya and
Eric because you have a unique perspective
because you have both been students
at the GSB and partners at the GSB.
So wondering if you can kind of shed some
insights there in terms of some things
that might be helpful for
folks to consider from either perspective.
Whether they're students coming with their
partners or what that partner experience
might be like now that you've
seen it from both perspectives.
>> Yeah, I would say that if it's possible
if your partner is planning to apply to
school, definitely do
the exact same thing we did.
Because then the second person to
go really has a leg up because they
have the expert in the room and
all social meetups, which is great.
No, I think it's a great
question Christine, and
there's probably a lot of different
ways we could go with it.
I think the first one is really important,
as actually Natalya as already mentioned,
is deciding whether or
not you're going to be in the same place.
And that might be other question for other
families on the line, but for us it was
an important conversation of would, I've
moved to San Francisco or the Bay Area.
And kind of live either in person or
even just like that middle
distance between San Francisco and
living on campus.
And that's ultimately what we did when
she was a student, as I was living in
San Francisco, and she was living
down in the Bay and we made it work.
And it kind of kept a little bit
of distance in kids and things.
So I think that's a really
important question to consider is
kind of optimizing for
that work life balance.
And if your partner is interested in
investing more in the community, and
kind of having kind of a more
individual exposure to their class,
and really getting some of
those opportunities that
might not be something that
a working person is keen to do.
Then that's an important conversation
to have in setting those boundaries and
expectations.
>> And I think for us, both of us found
a lot of happiness in having one-on-one
relationships with
the other person's class.
So, for example,
I wasn't relying on my happiness and
my schedule just through Eric.
I feel like I had individual
relationships with his classmates.
And that in of itself,
I think makes it a lot easier and
much more fruitful for
the partner and also for
the student because then there
is sort of like an independence.
And it's not fully kind of
a co-dependence as you're kind of
building your own life on campus.
>> Thank you both.
Amanda, Tori, I'd love to hear because
I know you've faced similar choices,
relocating from an international location,
figuring out long distance, and
moving on campus.
Can you talk to the group a little bit
about how you navigated that process?
>> I'm happy to go first.
Gosh, it was an interesting experience.
I mean, we started doing long distance,
which was really necessary
given the COVID pandemic.
It was, [LAUGH] so
much choice, it's necessity.
And that was, we made that work for us.
We sorted out some rhythms.
Obviously, we had a very significant
time difference between the two of us.
I was in Melbourne and
Amanda was in Palo Alto,
but we made it work by putting in time.
And because some couples may be
thinking about doing long distance or
may have to do long distance because
of visa reasons for quite a while,
we put time in each other's calendars.
Every week that was reserved for
us to hang out with each other.
Life can be really busy on campus at
Stanford and it's also exciting and
new, that it can be hard to make time for
other things in your life.
So we made sure to have some dedicated
time where Amanda wasn't allowed,
[LAUGH] to go and
do something else, no, I'm joking.
So we made that work for us.
We did long distance for,
gosh, five months, I think.
And then moving on campus,
we spent some time just making
sure that we got settled in.
And Amanda was really proactive about
making sure that I felt welcomed and
included.
Introduced me to a lot of her friends and
I found it quite easy
to settle into the community actually,
which was great.
Everyone was super welcoming.
And yeah, we had a great time.
>> Well, and this is actually
a great segue to ask Amanda,
you mentioned living in J Mac and Schwab.
So I am going to go out and
make a little bit of an assumption
that you might have started at J Mac.
And then when you were
able to move in together,
you were able to make the move to
the couple's housing in Schwab.
So for others who may be dialing in, who
may be facing a similar situation where
they might have to start long distance,
but there may be an opportunity for
their partner to join later.
Can you talk a little bit about
how you navigated that process?
>> Yes.
>> I think, Amanda-
>> Sorry.
>> Your back.
Start again.
>> Sorry, my Internet connection
is not great, so I apologize.
Plan early.
So we knew that Tori was going to arrive
at the start of the winter quarter-ish,
with, We communicated on,
have I gone off again?
Yeah, I'm just going to let Tori,
>> I we'll try and
interpret what Amanda was going,
[LAUGH] to say.
From what I recall, yes,
we definitely planned early.
Amanda knew when I was going to arrive,
so she was in contact with At
the GSB residences and I fell on
about what rooms might be available
particularly as the terms changed over.
Because there is some shift in and
out of people in Schwab and J Mac.
[LAUGH] I hope I'm reading your mind
correctly it's a long distance to read.
>> [CROSSTALK].
>> [LAUGH] So, we actually found
a room in Schwab sometimes, I mean,
the couple rooms very popular.
I wouldn't say that they're
difficult to get when moving in
because they are kind of
a modification of two single rooms.
So they can kind of make
couple rooms happen, but
they need a bit of warning
to to make that happen.
So, we just worked early with
the GSB residences and they were
able to have a couple's room available for
us when we moved in which was great.
>> Now also we did
consider other options so
we do know lots of partners who do other
>> Amanda, maybe if you had off video,
we might still be able to catch
your audio we can give that a try.
All right,
we may have to come back to Amanda there.
>> Just engaged via chat
>> It's okay [LAUGH]
>> Fantastic please do I'm going to
switch gears a little bit now thank
you all for your context there.
I think that's very helpful because I know
housing can be something that can make
folks anxious because there are so
many options.
But for our couples, as I mentioned,
in addition to the Schwab couples housing.
Couples may also live at Escondido village
or in Mongar so lots of options on campus.
Something else that's come up now a couple
of times in q&a are the options for
daycare or childcare on campus.
So Parker and Lacey, I'm wondering if
that's something that you utilize and
might be able to speak to or
if you know any classmates that did.
I don't want to rush around too much
looking for the links on the site, but
I can try if either of you can maybe
get us started in that conversation.
>> So I did just post the link I think
it would go through to the daycare.
And we did not use the daycare on campus
but we have lots of friends who did.
I will say that when you're moving
to campus it was probably about 50,
50 of parents that were both working.
Or parents who may be working before and
then decided not to just
during that experience.
Or parents who were just stay at home
parents because that's a decision that
they had made.
So there's not really a right or
wrong way to do that.
But the childcare options offered
at Stanford are actually really,
really great.
I've had some friends claim that they're
the best teachers you can find anywhere
in the country which might
be the truth [LAUGH].
And in particular Madeira Grove and
CCSC have had a lot of positive feedback,
at least what we are that
which was two years ago, but
I imagine not too much
has changed in that time.
And specifically, one friend who heard her
two young daughters were there during all
the COVID stuff.
And just really impressed with the ways
that they handled all of that for
young children because that's I mean their
world was shaken, was disrupted too.
And that being said the waitlist
can be quite long so
if that is something that
you are interested in.
It's a good idea to reach out early and
often.
And then also during COVID a lot of
people have been using nanny shares.
And that happened while we were there too
but you just get your Escondido neighbors
right next door or whatever and
you can just hire somebody together.
And that was a good solution for
a lot of people.
Somebody asked about the what how
the schools are handling COVID now and
we are left before COVID hit
we graduated in 2019 [LAUGH].
But I have heard that kindergarteners and
first graders and
second graders were back in
person at the end of last year.
So if you have children older than that,
let me know but
at least those kids are back in person and
planning to do start again in the fall.
>> Thanks, Lacey and I did my best to try
to add the the link there in the chat,
which I think is open to everyone.
This next question is from Rashmi and
I think I'm going to direct this to Eric.
Because Eric, you mentioned that when you
were the partner, you were actually living
off campus during that experience
living up in San Francisco.
So Rashmi has a partner who will
need to commute in the South Bay.
I'm wondering if you can
maybe speak to the pros and
cons of living off campus
versus living on campus.
And I think now you're in a position
where you've seen it both ways
>> Yes I can definitely share a few
thoughts on that.
So as you mentioned,
I was living in San Francisco and
Natalya was living on campus and
Schwab and I did not own a car either.
So I had the double fun time of using many
modes of public transit to get to and
from where we needed to go.
But I will say it is it is quite
doable there is options to it.
It's very easy to get to the Caltrain
which usually gets you to just about any
major city that I don't know
where in the South Bay.
Your partner might be working but
I can bet that there's probably a caltrain
stop that gets you pretty close.
And then there's several other options for
public transit if you have a car,
which is maybe advisable.
If you are going to be having
a daily commute into work,
once things start to lift up.
There's ample parking options on
campus for an additional cost and
you could drive down to and
from the South Bay.
Or if you need to commute up
to San Francisco as well but
I think the obvious downside is
that there's some additional
commuting to get to campus
if you're living together.
So that's just something else to keep in
mind is you have multiple cars if you're
living in Palo Alto,
one of you needs to commute to campus.
And one of you needs to go down to
the South Bay or something like that so
just as any consideration there as well.
>> I would say also, a lot of the people
who have partners off campus but or
who are local.
There'll be a Slack or
WhatsApp group where people do ride share.
So, hey, I need to ride up to San
Francisco, who else is going to go visit
their partner for the weekend or
even on a weeknight?
That's a fun way if you don't have
a car to carpool with people and
it makes it a lot more efficient.
>> Great, thanks I thought I saw
a question a little earlier I don't
see it now.
So I'm guessing somebody may have answered
it in the chat but for the partners
on the call who were navigating,
job searches here in the Bay Area.
Can anyone speak to that experience?
Just out of curiosity like Tori or
Eric, did you come with jobs already?
Or did you end up utilizing
the Career Center resources as a partner?
>> I mean,
I can go first I did come with a job and
I was not looking to use any of the CMC or
Career Resources, I think to Tori's point.
She made earlier there are so
many events and there's so
many opportunities to kind of network.
And kind of expand your your horizons and
get to meet people,
which is of course advantageous
to the career of a partner.
But I did not use any I guess
formal resources through
the Career Management Center.
>> I did reach out and
I'm not going to explain the bizarre
circumstances that I was going through.
But initially I was looking for a job and
did work with the Career Center
to be put onto some leads.
They do offer their support to partners.
My understanding is it's not the same
as the support they offer to students,
which is very extensive for partners.
They will do some things but
I believe not everything.
And they put me on to some Stanford
connections in the areas that I was
interested in,
which was obviously a great help.
And I definitely got some interviews
from some of those leads,
which was really helpful.
Someone else to put in the chat,
can partners work?
It depends where you're from.
Make sure if you're an international
you know your visa situation,
what visa you're applying for.
What your ability to work
is because in my situation,
if I wanted to work in the US, I had
to have an employer, and be sponsored.
And have that contract before I could even
get my visa to actually go over to the US.
So, be very careful because it can take,
I would allow, like.
Depending on your situation upto 6 months
for your job search and visa process.
It took me probably 2, 3 months to make
that happen in terms of getting a new job.
In the end I ended up sticking
with my current employer who
did an intercompany transfer
to from Australia to the US.
Which was actually the most
straightforward way for me.
So if you work for
a multinational company, I would
recommend exploring that route, [LAUGH].
So yeah, I did use the standard
data ratios available.
Make sure you give a lot of time and
do a lot of research.
>> Great, thank you.
I'm going to turn things over to
the students now to hear your perspective.
And again, this is speaking from
just your own personal experience.
What we tell people as they're thinking
about applying to Stanford is that really
every class is different.
Every class sort of takes on
a personality of its own.
And in any given year,
we don't know how many people may be
applying with partners or families.
So curious to hear from Parker, Natalia,
Eric, Amanda, of your class experiences.
Can you describe the families and
partners kind of life on campus
in terms of how active the partners and
families were in your class.
Because I know sometimes
that can shift year to year,
some years there seems to be more
groups of families than others.
So just curious from your own personal
perspective, some of the things that stand
out in your mind And Amanda,
feel free to pop yours in
chat if we're worried about you're coming
in clear right now but just in case.
>> Yeah, I can I can just share
a couple thoughts real fast.
So, I definitely think that
they might have been lazy or or
someone who who mentioned it.
And again, having been on both
sides it really is around how much
partners I think put into wanting
to invest in the community.
Wanting to be part of it
wanting to be active and
I think it's incumbent on
the students to be welcoming.
And to be inviting and
I think more often than not.
I can think of instances where Natalia and
I would just kind of add
the other person to an invite.
Or, bring them along for a dinner and
I think that's very well received.
And I think it starts to create that kind
of momentum around building as Natalia
said, does one on one relationships.
And I found some of the most,
I think, memorable and
engaging experiences I've had
with partners as well as.
Again, on the other side of the table
to be taking that time to reach out,
be proactive as an SEO.
To try to create those one
on one relationships, and
I think it actually goes a long way
towards bettering your experience.
And making you feel like a larger part
of the community as you go through that,
your time at the GSB.
>> And I also think beyond social
mean there's like a million
plus events that as an SEO.
Become a part of whether it's small
form or even larger form, but
from a professional standpoint,
there's also a lot of upside.
So a couple of examples
that come to mind is one,
sometimes GSB students can help
you prepare for job interviews.
I know some of my classes or classmates
helped Eric prepare for his interviews.
Another example is we had.
I can think of three SEOs or
three partners from my classes here
who actually started companies
with some of my classmates.
So professionally,
they were very integrated in
terms of the startup community.
But also even the more like,
traditional career route
aspects of the GSB
>> I'm going to try and get my internet to
hold just set it sensitive
GSB partners are awesome.
Like this is not like a Just
an SEO like tag along with.
The people that I have met who
are partners are a genuine friends of mine
some of whom I've connected
with more closely.
Then other students in my class,
like a friend of mine who's in so
we go rock climbing together.
I haven't met anybody else who
has that same passion as I do,
class community, [COUGH].
More like surfing or
we have really interesting.
Maybe, I'm sorry we have interesting
discussions on things that are outside
of the gym.
[LAUGH] I got my main point across.
And so that's awesome, I love them.
You're a huge part of community and
you enrich it so much.
So yeah, that's all, [LAUGH].
>> Couldn't have said it any better.
Parker is there anything else you'd
like to add anything that from
the family lanes?
>> Yeah, I just was always so impressed
with how my classmates would engage,
not just with Lacey, but with our kids.
And so, that was always just super
fun to see that side of everybody
that maybe you don't always
see in a work environment.
Or something like that,
or classroom environment.
And I cannot honestly think
of a time where Lacey came
along where,
we weren't both super welcome.
And, just part of the community.
So yeah, I think it really is great and
to have made friends with
other partners and or ESOs?
So yeah, I think not much else.
>> Thanks, everyone.
I'm going to address
a quick question here.
But for anyone who's maybe had this
experience, feel free to chime in.
Victor is wondering can partners
audit classes at the GSB.
So sort of officially you cannot
audit an entire class but for
partners who may have done this.
I do believe that if you have a student,
they may be able to request permission
from a faculty member for
you to sit in on a particular class.
I know sometimes that is at their
discretion depending on what might be
covered in the classroom.
But was anyone ever able
to attend a class or
two as a guest with faculty permission?
>> Yeah.
I'm sorry.
We're going crazy now, but we,
I think every single class that was
Parker's Top Favorite or I was able.
I don't think, I mean,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I don't think you ever want us
to take a CAM and withhold now.
I mean, I did try and
do a bunch of classes in
the same semester, but
I would do one here, so.
>> Great, thank you.
Speaking of the partner experience,
and I'm looking at the clock and
we've got a little bit of time left.
But I would love to hear a little
bit more about some of your personal
favorite experiences at the GSB.
We talked a little earlier.
About how many events and
social activities and
guest speakers are open to the the partner
and GSB community broadly.
So I'm wondering if any of you
have any favorite memories or
experiences that you
got to participate in.
Tell us.
>> Yeah [LAUGH] Good
reminder [INAUDIBLE] Yeah,
I'll share just a few things
that quickly come to mind.
First is actually I think ties into
auditing classes a little bit.
There's just such a special
group of lecturers and
professors that work at the GSB and
almost all of them are willing and
open to having dinners or
interactions outside of class.
And so Natasha and
I actually had a really awesome,
like one on one, I guess double date with
with a professor and his wife last summer,
which I think is just a really
special kind of experience.
As an SRO to meet a professor just
that close and kind of see and
learn from him and his wife,
which was just a tremendous experience and
I anticipate that happening more.
Second is definitely travelling.
I think there's a lot of opportunities,
because someone mentioned it's mostly
the student led group trips that you can
go on, but those are really special
ways to really solidify those bonds.
And to feel like part of the community and
hopefully, with some COVID restrictions
and things like that are listening there
might be more opportunities to do that,
especially for incoming classes.
And the third thing,
which I think is really valuable is,
I'm sure most of you who are applying
to the GSB have heard of touchy feely,
which is a very prominent course
that a lot of students take.
And then I actually as an so
had the chance to engage in
a touchy feely weekend retreat.
Which was a tremendous,
important and impactful experience.
And having now taken the full class I
can say it really does match with what
you learn in the course itself and
there's just a lot of ways to think.
Kind of develop yourself emotionally and
mentally through that type of a program.
And so I would encourage you all to
investigate that as you embark on your
journeys.
>> Thanks Eric, Lacey Tory,
any favorites for you?
>> Mine is definitely the class troops.
I mean, we had a very unusual
year as I think Eric alluded to,
in that those who are probably
the primary way that the class
really had the chance to
get to know one another.
So it was really awesome
to be able to Skiing,
explore some of the national parks
around California do Yosemite and
that was really fun to get to go
camping with some of the class.
I really enjoyed it.
>> I actually did like the traveling also,
we probably did it as much but
the trips are always memorable.
And also, there's a, I can't remember
what it's called anymore, secrecy.
What does it stand for?
But, [LAUGH] anyway,-
>> Stands for charity.
>> Okay, okay, yes.
And I just thought the involvement
there was really fun.
There's just a lot of great energy because
you're thinking about something that's
bigger than yourself which is kind
of the whole point of Samford.
Like this whole thing.
That was a great experience for
me personally and for Angeline.
>> Thanks, Lacey.
Well keeping an eye on the clock here,
I'd love if we can kind of wrap up and
kind of pull this all together.
If we think about our audience here today.
Many of the folks on the line are thinking
about applying in the next year or two.
And so if you can all reflect
back to a year or two,
three or so ago when you were in their
shoes and you were thinking about
this big decision to come to business
school either as the student or
as part of a couple that was
pursuing that journey together.
What advice might you have for
the students, the partners,
the families out there as they're
thinking about business school and
they're kind of at the front
line here of this journey?
Any pieces of advice or tips or
suggestions that you would make for
the group today as they
take the next steps?
>> I'm happy to go.
So I do remember throughout
the application process feeling kind
of constantly intimidated by people
that I met who had attended the GSP.
Or you're sort of reading into every
little detail on the admissions website.
So it's like, okay,
I see somebody that did McKinsey.
And I see somebody else who's
founded some incredible nonprofit.
I didn't do either of those
things that seems bad.
And so
I think just getting past all of that and
just really focusing on your own story and
your own goals and
the experience that you'd like to
create for your own MBA program.
And not trying to not trying to guess
what like the admissions committee
wants to hear anything like that, and I
think Once I arrived at Stanford, I was so
blown away by the incredible diversity
on every possible dimension,
including diversity of experience, and
there is no traditional background.
At Stanford, there's no playbook for
getting into Stanford.
So I think just, for those of you who
are about to write those essays or
take the GMAT or whatever you're going to
do, just have some confidence that there's
somebody that's just like you that
got into Stanford at some point.
And so you have, like you will have
a shot to get in as much as anybody does.
So, yeah,
that's what I would say about that.
>> Thanks, Parker, and thank you
Amanda for weighing in on chat there.
Natalia, Eric, anything come to mind for
either of you today?
>> This is more advice for, I guess,
as you think about your class and
your class is a big part
of your identity but
both the partner in the student should
think about there's so many events and
opportunities to interact with the class
above you and below you as well.
I think that's sometimes
an opportunity that can be missed.
And so if you and your partner kind
of plan to make sure that you don't
just invest in the class that you're
a part of, but also the other classes.
There's a lot of great like cross
pollination that can happen there,
whether it's through social events or
even things like the women's golf clinic.
There's all of these opportunities.
>> Great advice.
All right,
we'd love to hear from the partners
thinking about the partner experience.
Anything you did or in hindsight
wished you could have done in terms of
supporting your students as they
were embarking on this experience.
Or to the partners out there anything
you want to give them a heads up on?
>> Yeah, I'll just I'll throw one
out there which is be flexible,
be adaptable and
be willing to ask questions.
I think as it as a partner
the especially fall quarter when there
is just an inundation a day lusion
of new things that are going
on that it's really important.
I think to establish expectations,
establish routines and
also recognize that the GSB can be
a really quirky place and sometimes
you might be like why is my partner
prioritizing they're not over this.
And I think it's just
kind of leaning into and
being slightly flexible as
this experience really is.
Transformational in so many different
ways and both for a partner and for
the student themselves.
And so yeah, I think being adaptable and
flexible and
to ever said it earlier setting
expectations in the US is really critical.
>> And, I agree with that.
I also agree with what Amanda said
in the chat about working together.
[LAUGH] And from the beginning, would have
been included whole of admissions process.
And everybody's going to
have their own experience,
but for us I will always talk
about the GSB like it was ours.
Even though I didn't get a graduate
degree from the Stanford Graduate School
of Business.
Because I changed my life just
as much as I changed his and
it disrupted and interrupted and
it transformed us too.
And so for me,
it was important that I was involved.
Every step of the way I read, every essay,
I read every application, and
I celebrated the same way
when he got his call.
And, so I think that that was something
that made it important for us.
Is that we were in it together from
the very beginning until the end.
>> Thank you Lacey Tory.
>> I'll definitely echo that
the only thing I would add is
depending on sort of where you are.
Whether you're on campus or whether you're
like a million miles away just try.
Just make sure that you try and
get involved in whatever way it is like
it makes life more fun and interesting.
If you're not just kind of focused on
your own life and your own work and
you try and get involved.
In meeting your partner's
Stanford friends and
going along to events and
trips, because you're.
I'm get so much more out of the
experience, the more that you're involved,
and Echo,Eric and Lacey's input as well.
>> Well, thank you all so much.
I truly cannot thank you enough for
spending your time with us today,
especially for those of you who kept
some very odd hours to join us.
I really do appreciate it.
I just shared my screen for
one last moment here.
So for those of you who joined us today,
thank you.
We do hope this has been helpful for
you to give you a better
sense of the partners.
And families experience here at
Stanford's Graduate School of Business.
For those of you who are continuing
this journey and planning to apply soon.
I encourage you to check out and
create your own personalized dashboard
as you go through this experience.
On MyStanford.mba, and a quick plug for
some upcoming events from our office.
We're actually hosting an application
week at the first week in August.
So for those of you who
are planning to apply this year or
just want to do some early prep for
the future.
Our office will be hosting
a number of workshops and
sessions the first week in August.
To help you and guide you through
that application process.
So while you are hopefully turning to
your partners and they're helping you,
proofread and edit those essays.
If you're also looking for some advice
from us or just some guidance to help get
you over that finish line
to hit submit in September.
We hope you'll join us for
some of those sessions.
So a huge thank you again to our panel.
Thank you so much,
it was lovely to see you all.
And thanks to all of you for
spending some time with us today.
So best wishes and we look forward
to seeing your application soon.
Take care, everyone.
[MUSIC]